ASSEMBLY BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE IS CALLED
TO ORDER WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
BUT WE CAN START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WELCOME TO THE TO
YOUR BILL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WHETHER YOU ARE HERE
IN PERSON WATCHING VIRTUALLY OR
ON THE PHONE LINES I AM GRATEFUL
THAT YOU HAVE JOINED US IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. I WILL NOT GO
OVER SOME KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S HEARING AND
DUE TO ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
TAKING THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS A SAFE HEARING
MASK ARE REQUIRED TO BE WORN AT
ALL TIMES AND WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHORS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA FOR TODAY WE WILL
ALLOW TESTIMONY EITHER IN PERSON
OR BY PHONE FOR THOSE TESTIFYING
IN PERSON PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
WHEN PROMPTED AND I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ONCE YOU
FINISH. TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT FOR THOSE USING THE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 1-877-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR TV OR
MONITOR SCREEN IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEING- IS IN
THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
COMMUTING EXTREME BROADCAST
ANDERSON DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION IF YOU ARE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO ONE FOUR AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE. TO HELP. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. ONE LAST
POINT. THIS YEAR PROTESTERS HAVE
APPEARED AT LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS. REMOVING THEIR MASKS
YELLING FROM THE AUDIENCE AND
ISSUING VEILED THREATS ABOUT
POTENTIAL GUN VIOLENCE. IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH. FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE
WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT. THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR
OR BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE. EVEN VEILED
THREATS WE APPLY THESE RULES TO
ALL PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE IN
OUR PROCEEDINGS. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US. AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THAT. WE
ALL FACE. AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH FOR A QUORUM. AND
SO SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GRAYSON THEY'RE
FACING HERE CHEN. THERE CAN.
BURKE CERVANTES CERVANTES HERE
CHOI CHOI HERE GABRIEL. CRISTINA
GARCIA HERE IN A GARCIA HERE
WHEN THE PLAN HERE PETRIE-NORRIS
. YEAH PETRIE-NORRIS HERE STONE
STONE HERE WICKS. SEVEN OKAY WE
DO WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
AND WE ARE GOING TO GO OUT OF
ORDER IF THAT IS OKAY WITH THE
OTHER AUTHORED WHICH IT APPEARS
IT IS SO WE DO HAVE SB FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AMENDMENTS ARE
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
INCLUDE THE ADOPTION OF AN
URGENCY CLAUSE CENTER LIMÓN WHEN
YOU ARE READY PLEASE BEGIN WITH
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU HAVE A MOVING THE
BILL FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
AND A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ABOUT. FIGURE MEMBERS AS
WANT TO SAY THE URGENCY CLAUSE
IS PUT ON THERE BECAUSE IT'S
MAKING AN EXEMPTION FOR
ENTERTAINMENT MAKE ONE
COMMERCIAL LOAN IN A MATTER OF
TWELVE MONTHS SO I APPRECIATE IT
NINETY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT BRIEF
TESTIMONY. WE DO- WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY IDENTIFIED PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL BE MOVING ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. MODERATOR ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NOT IN KILL ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE
MODERATOR OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. YEAH THERE ARE NONE
IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. HEARING AND SEEING NONE DOES
THE AUTHOR WAS TO PROVIDE A
CLOSING STATEMENT. THEY ASK FOR
AN EVENT THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
SENATOR AND WITH THAT I DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND AND THE
PLEASE NOTE TO THE MEMBERS THAT
THIS IS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
REQUIREMENT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GRAYSON HI.
GRAYSON HI CHEN. THERE CAN BURKE
CERVANTES HI CERVANTES AYE CHOI
AYE CHOI HI. APRIL. CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I WENT
WHEN I. NORSE BETWEEN NORTH AYE
STONE STONE I WICKS. IT'S YES
SEVEN MONTHS. SO THE VOTERS
SEVEN TO ONE AND WE WILL HOLD
THE- I'M SORRY SEVEN ZERO THE
VOTERS SEVEN ZERO SORRY CENTER
VOTE AND- WE WILL HOLD THE WILL
HOLD THE VOTE COUNT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YES WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE CONSENT FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA. AND WE DO HAVE A SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES.
SECTOR WE PLEASE CALL. EMOTIONS
DAY PASSED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE CHAN. AMERICAN BURKE
. CERVANTES CERVANTES I CHOI HI
CHOI AYE GABRIEL. CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I WENT.
WHEN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
GENERICIZED DON'T STONE HI WICKS. SEVEN SO THE VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO WE WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AS WELL
WE WOULD LIKE TO GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
YOU ARE UP. THE RECOMMENDATION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BILL WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA AND A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
APPRECIATE YOUR HEARING OF THIS
BILL AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY ONE
WHICH WOULD CREATE SIMPLE
PROTECTIONS THAT HELP PREVENT
FRAUDULENT LLC FILINGS- IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER BUT I THINK IT'S A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD PIECE OF
LEGISLATION A MUCH NEEDED TO
HELP PREVENT. SOME OF THE TYPES
OF FRAUD THAT WERE SEEN OUT
THERE TODAY I DO. HAVE A WITNESS
TODAY ANTHONY HELTON- BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION- WITH THAT I ASPIRO
. THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME
REMEMBER AND- WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS- THAT WILL BE TESTIFYING
AS MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR OVER
THE PHONE ANTHONY HELTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION MODERATORS WOULD YOU
PLEASE CONNECT US. HI MISTER
SHARON HERE I THANK YOU ALL I'LL
KEEP MY BECAUSE MANY BRIEFS. AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE I NEED AFFECTS-
WANT TO THANK- THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE STAFF- SECURED STATE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL-
IT'S INTENDED TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING CAPABILITIES WITHIN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S THE THUMB.
AND WHILE WE THINK- MORE COULD
BE DONE TO PREVENT THIS TYPE OF
FRAUD WE THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN THE
PROCESS. WITH THAT SAID
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
TESTIMONY AND MODERATOR OTHER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NONE THANK
YOU AND ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NON WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY IDENTIFIED PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL OPEN IT UP TO THE PUBLIC
MODERATOR OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NOT THANK YOU MODERATOR AND ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND WE- I HAVE NONE SO TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SINCE WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
THANK YOU JEFFERSON ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE- SOON AS
I DISCUSSED WITH YOU- I WONDER
IF. THERE IS ANY ROOM. TO IN%
HAND SO YOUR BILL RATHER THAN
JUST- NOTIFYING THE EMBASSY OWN
ARE- AFTER SOMEBODY HOURS SO HAS
ATTEMPTED TO MAKE ANY CHANGES
THIS IS UP TO PREVENT ANY
FRAUDULENT- ACTIVITIES. SO THAT
IS A REALLY GOOD. BUT I WONDER
IF OUTWEIGHS THE ENERGY OWNER.
INITIALLY I SHOULD OWN AND I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONTROL IT.
AND HOW COULD YOU BE ABLE TO
ACCESS TO MY FILE MY DATA AND
THE MAKE UP. OF MODIFICATIONS-
AND THEN- STATE SECRETARY ONLY
INFORMS ME JUST WATER SOMETHING
SOMEBODY DID SOME CHANGES.
ALREADY TOO LATE. SO I WAS SO
WONDERING IF I WHEN I FIGHT IT
AND THEN I CAN JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER LACK OF BANKING. OF TALENT
ACTIVITIES SO HI THE SYSTEM
ORDER DIDN'T REQUIRE ME TO
IDENTIFY WHO I AM AND THE FROM
THERE I CAN CREATE THE PASSWORD.
SO AT THE START OF THE OR P. UP
BIG UP EVERY YEAR FALL ANY
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES SO THE
ACCESS OF TO BEGIN WITH. OUR
WHETHER THERE IS ANY. CHANCE
THIS BILL CAN BE IMPROVED THE
WAR THAT HAS TO BE A SECOND UP A
SEPARATE STATE. YEAH YEAH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU AND
YOU KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THAT I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY GOOD IDEA-
WOULD DEFINITELY INCREASE THE
SECURITY- MORE WORK I'M A
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO. YOU KNOW
FIGURE OUT HOW HOW WHAT THEIR
CAPABILITIES ARE AND HOW WE CAN
DO THIS RIGHT NOW IT JUST DOES
THE NOTICE BUT I'M OPEN TO
OTHER. SECURITY MEASURES THAT
WOULD ENHANCE THAT TO MAKE SURE
MAKE IT SO SOMEBODY CAN'T
CHANGER- YOU KNOW HERE MANAGER
STATUS OR OFFICER STATUS
WITHOUT- WITHOUT YOU KNOWING
ABOUT IT. RIGHT SO DEFINITELY
OPEN TO THAT BUT I MEAN AT THIS
POINT. AND I AND I THINK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. WE'LL TRY AND SEE
IF WE CAN ADD SOME FURTHER
SECURITY MEASURES. I THINK. YOU
CAN. MAKE IT- YES IF YOUR
INITIAL. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENTS- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
THIS. ON YOUR BILL WITH THAT I
DO HAVE A MOTION AND I DO HAVE A
SECOND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MASON HI THE PAST COMEDIAN
PREPARATIONS GRAYSON I. GEN
AMERICAN HI WHERE CAN I BURKE
BURKE I CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE
CHOI HI JULIE I CABLE. CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I WENT
WHEN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I STONE. I WICKS.
HIS NINE BOTH HIS NINE BOTH THE
VOTERS NINE ZERO SO THE BILL
DOES GET OUT AND WE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS SECTOR
WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THAT HAVE SHOWN UP IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO THROUGH AND- CALL
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. CHEN
AMERICAN SNIPER OKAY WHAT ABOUT
SEVENTY. AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY ONE
DO PASSED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHEN. GABRIEL
WICKS MISTER KNIGHT. IF CONSENT
AB SEVEN SIXTEEN NINETY PASSED
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CHEN
. CAN CAN I BURKE BURKE AYE
CABLE WICKS. THIS NINETEENTH.
THAT'S NINE ZERO SO THAT BILL
PASSES AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HOLD OPEN FOR JUST A COUPLE MORE
MINUTES THAT'S SB FIVE SEVEN.
NOW THAT WITHIN FIFTEEN OKAY
THANKS FOR. SB FIVE SEVEN
SEVENTY PASSED AS AMENDED
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CHEN
. BEAR CAMP THERE CAN I BURKE
BURKE I GABRIEL WICKS. IT IS MY
VOTES. NINE VOTES NINE VOTES THE
BILL ALSO GETS OUT AND AGAIN WE
WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR JUST A
MINUTE OR TWO LONGER FOR MEMBERS
THAT ARE ABSENT.
IT APPEARS WE
HAVE ABSENT MEMBERS THAT HAVE
SHOWN UP MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
BILLS STILL ON CALL. AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE TO PASSED
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
APRIL. APRIL I WICKS WICKS HI.
HAS ELEVEN BOTH. ELEVEN ZERO
THIS BILL AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY ONE
IS OUT OF COMMITTEE. THIS
CONSENT AB SEVEN SIXTY NINETY
PASSED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GABRIEL. GABRIEL
I WICKS WICKS HI THE BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTES. AB SEVEN SIXTY
NINE ELEVEN VOTES ELEVEN ZERO
THE BILLS OUT OF COMMITTEE. AB
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GABRIEL. GABLE I
WICKS WICKS I WAS ELEVEN VOTES.
SB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN ELEVEN ZERO
THIS BILL ALSO IS OUT OF
COMMITTEE WE HAVE COMPLETED OUR
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE
WILL BE LEAVING- OR WE ARE NOT
CLOSING ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
VOTED. AND YOU SEE A GUY DO WANT
TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO THE
VICE CHAIR. THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
STAFF THE RULES COMMITTEE STAFF
THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER THE
MODERATOR AND ALL TO INSURE THAT
THIS. MEETING COULD TAKE PLACE
THIS HEARINGS SO SIMPLY BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED. AND WE'RE.